I had to kind of like without even
realizing it beat down some of my
femininity and some of my Natural
Instincts the way I am at home is
completely different from the way that I
am on camera I was able to separate
those worlds but I didn't even realize
what I was doing until I really thought
about it and it was interesting because
when I met my husband he would always
say you're so quiet like off of TV like
I would go out and people wouldn't even
know I was there I just wanted to kind
of absorb what was happening I don't
need to be talking all the time I'm very
shy I'm the first person to be like I
can't come to the party I don't want to
go I just want to hang out at home but
on TV people see this person and I'm
like it's it's like a split personality
but I did have to beat down my
femininity to survive in that world and
I don't recommend it because I was never
happy there yeah I was always unhappy I
always felt like I was in someone else's
outfit or trying to be something or
trying to do something because it was
unnatural for me